the palace of Sans Souci which roughly
translates as carefree was built in 1745
above terraced vineyards as a summer
residence for Prussian King Frederick
the Great he didn't want the surrounding
Park to be merely scenic it was designed
to be useful to its vineyards fruit and
fig trees still flourished today in the
past there was even greater abundance
Newton and taxes pure mean want we are
there were apple and pear trees that
have been replaced with use walnuts in
chestnut trees on the sides of the
terraces they were even pineapples and
strawberry fields as you can see behind
me the vines and fig trees were in
greenhouses so they could be harvested
earlier
the park remains a major tourist
attraction several eye catching
architectural features are scattered
around the grounds the white dome of the
castle on peacock Island is visible in
the distance above the treetops pawan
enzo as it's known in german is idyllic
ly situated in South West Berlin and can
only be reached by ferry it was acquired
in 1793 by frederick william ii
frederick the great successor who had
the castle built for himself and his
mistress his successor Frederick William
the third introduced a menagerie for
exotic animals later transferring all
the animals to the Berlin Zoo only
peacocks and some rare birds remain on
the island today in the early 19th
century a stay in Italy prompted Prince
Charles of Prussia to have the Glenna
commander converted into a neoclassical
palace with a landscaped garden in 1990
the palaces and parks of Potsdam and
Berlin created during centuries of
Prussian rulers were inscribed on UNESCO
World Heritage List over on the German
Polish border Moscow Park on the river
NASA is less structured but has its own
verdant charm
in fact it was also meticulously planned
laid out in the style of an English
garden in 1815 by Prince Herman from
popular Moscow a well-traveled nobleman
who was not only a writer but a
landscape gardener
after the Second World War the river
marked the border between Germany and
Poland with most of the park in Poland
as German Polish relations improved in
the 1990s the restoration of the park
became a focus of pioneering
cross-border cooperation first of all
the meadows were restored and the
overgrowth reduced so that the views
could be enjoyed once again olga shared
all steam decayed commands are
historical pathways were related so the
visitors can walk through the grounds
again and of course that included the
rebuilding of the double bridge across
the river nicer in 2003 these days the
park has been restored to its former
glory and looks pretty much as romantic
and unspoiled as its designer envisioned
it
the desolates garden realm was created
in the late 18th century under the
Regency of Duke Leopold the third of an
Hadassah
like Moscow Park it's inspired by the
traditional English garden javert anemic
English as a young man he was keen to
move to England but he wasn't allowed to
he was obliged to become Prince of
unheard Dessau and then Duke of unheard
SR so what he did was bring England to
Germany he created an English garden
here in Berlin it was one of the first
and largest English parks outside of
Britain the garden realm wasn't intended
to be enjoyed by nobility only Leopold's
vision was a park and a palace for
everyone
it's design reflected his interest in
the ancient world and in enlightenment
from Potsdam to Moscow park and Berlitz
the Prussian palaces and gardens express
an ideal of harmony between man and
nature